dans un instant je recevrai yolande
grobon la directrice adjointe à la
cohésion sociales des yvelines nous
verrons si le 115 est efficace et si les
hébergements d'urgence dans le
département sont suffisants pour
l'instant nous allons suivre une maraude
et ses interventions de la croix-rouge
qui permettent de venir en aide aux sans
domicile fixe fixe le département des
yvelines qui est toujours placé au
niveau 2 du plan hivernal
sous cas ces barres de céréales
couverture et produits d'hygiène les
équipes de la croix rouge et du samu
social se préparent pour leurs maraudes
quotidiennes en chemin la croix rouge
propose aux sans abri un accueil dans un
des quatre centres d'hébergement
sociales des yvelines
nous sommes une équipe de cette fille
salariés qui tournons 365 jours par an
du 15 heures à 23 heures voire minuit ou
plus tard s'il
ya nécessité pour aller à la rencontre
des personnes sans abri dans les
yvelines en tout les yvelines du nord au
sud
avec la lettre grand froid de niveau 2
déclenchées depuis mardi dernier le
passage de la croix rouge auprès des
sans abri et renforcer les équipes sont
plus nombreuses et plus insistantes
lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre en charge
ceux qui n'ont pas appelé le service
d'urgence vous avez pu manger annulant
l'évolution à l'est pas forcément
quantitative et qualitative
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir beaucoup
plus de jeunes qu'il ya dix ans par
exemple et on va observer aussi un
vieillissement de la population et
donc ça c'est de l'info qu'on s'adapte à
cette problématique et ja problèmes de
santé aussi au jour d'aujourd'hui
on est concentré à beaucoup de personnes
atteintes de maladies au xi ou maladies
somatiques la croix-rouge effectué onze
mille actions par an dans le département
son numéro le 115
bonsoir à yolande rebonds vous êtes la
directrice adjointe à la direction
départementale de la cohésion sociale
dans le département des yvelines la
fédération nationale des associations
d'accueil et de réinsertion sociale
vient de publier son baromètre hivernale
du 115 en début de semaine conclusion un
système saturer un appel sur deux n'est
pas prise en charge ça c'est un constat
national est ce que c'est le cas aussi
dans le département des yvelines nous
essayons justement de lutter contre
cette absence de réponse donc nous avons
travaillé sur l'accueil des personnes
accueil téléphonique des personnes et
notamment pour le week-end et notamment
en allongeant les durées de prise en
charge pour limiter le nombre d'appels
donc on peut dire que le 115 au jour
d'aujourd'hui est en capacité de
répondre mais jamais de manière
satisfaisante
on a toujours évidemment des personnes
qui n'arrivent pas à joindre le 115 mais
pour lutter contre ça nous avons allongé
comme je le disais les durées de prise
en charge pour l'hôtel par exemple c'est
tout de suite un mois ce qui évite aux
personnes d'art rappeler tous les jours
pour l'accueil d'urgence c'est pareil la
veille du week-end on assure également
pour tout le week-end ce qui fait
diminuer le nombre d'appels pendant le
week-end on rappelle que le 115 a bien
sûr c'est ce numéro d'urgence pour les
sans abri à une hausse véritablement des
appels en ce moment avec le froid qui a
été plus dur ces derniers jours et qui
devrait encore s'intensifier d'ailleurs
dans les prochaines 48 heures oui au
niveau national c'est une hausse de 22%
à peu près des demandes d'hébergement
sur une année et il ya eu il ya eu plus
de 59 presque soixante mille appels en
décembre dernier sur la france oui les
appels sont en moyenne autour de
et aujourd'hui il dépasse les 300 350
mais ce week end par exemple on a pu
constater une chute parce que justement
on avait anticipé en gardant les gens
plus longtemps il ya un système une
nouveauté on va dire qu'il s'est mis
également en place vous rappelez
automatiquement même si la personne qui
vous contacterons 115 n'arrive pas à
vous joindre vous enregistrez le numéro
et la possibilité de la recontacte voilà
c'est ça elle peut laisser son numéro
d'appel et on les rappelle même près
tard le soir jusqu'à 22 heures jusqu'à
23h30 par exemple puisqu'il ya un point
qui effet de saturation du dispositif
vers 20h 20h30 et ensuite s'il reste des
places et on reprend les appelle et on
essaye de joindre les personnes parce
que là donc on parle du 115 mais
forcément derrière ya ce problème ou non
d'ailleurs de nombre de places
disponibles on le sait dans dans
certaines régions certains départements
l'indre et loire la marne par exemple et
qui détiennent le record de non
attribution de place pour les sans abri
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas suffisamment
de place pour accueillir les sdf est ce
que dans les yvelines on est dans la
même tendance où il ya suffisamment de
place au jour d'aujourd'hui on a zéro
personnes à la rue
donc ça veut dire que toute personne qui
vous qu'on doit à personne trouvera un
logement tout le contact qui arrive à
nos jeunes que nous pouvons rejoindre
ensuite peut avoir un hébergement on
augmente les capacités pas de manière
indéfinie mais par rapport à l'année
passée nous avons plus de 60 % de places
supplémentaires à la fois en hôtel et en
structures combien de places
concrètement qui existe aujourd'hui dans
le département alors cent mille 118
places pérennes auxquels s'ajoutent
dispositif hivernal du 360 et une place
est ce que sont des places où les
familles peuvent venir également
s'installer parce que là aussi c'est une
changement au cours de ces dernières
années il ya de plus en plus de familles
qui vos contacts qui se retrouvent à la
rue des femmes des hommes qui sont
isolées avec des enfants elles peuvent
prétendre à une place également vous
pouvez les accueillir on a essayé cette
année de travail et para publics
accueillis c'est à dire que on a ouvert
deux centres qui permettent d'accueillir
des femmes ce qui évite la mixité dans
des centres où il y avait des problèmes
parfois de violence donc nous avons deux
centres qui accueillent les femmes nous
avons des centres d'urgence 2 qui
accueille des hommes il les nous avons
effectivement des centres où il y a ce
sont des centres qui ne sont pas ouverts
que l'hiver mais dans lequel nous avons
réservé des places supplémentaires pour
les familles et quand il y à des
familles à la rue avec enfants nous
avons donné des instructions pour que
ces femmes soient et ses enfants soient
pris en charge à l'hôtel donc si besoin
on ouvre des chambres d'hôtel
supplémentaires qui sont préservés et
qui ne seront utilisées que si besoin
les vous constatez véritablement
aujourd'hui c'est demande en hausse pour
les familles oui c'est une réalité aussi
dans le département des yvelines c'est
40 % de hausse sur un an au niveau
national oui on constate le même
phénomène dans le département est-ce que
les gens viennent qu'au delà des
yvelines aussi parce que de plus en plus
les gens contacteur au delà dans les
autres départements pour venir par
exemple parce qu'il ya suffisamment de
places en tout cas vous nous dites oui
alors c'est une des difficultés que l'on
monte cette année c'est que les
personnes appellent plusieurs 115 comme
les 115 ne sont pas encore connectés
ensemble dont qu'ils appellent ils
réservent des places et puis ils
prennent la place qu il l intérêt ce qui
les intéresse ce qui fait qu'il peut y
avoir c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il y a
le soir des places disponibles donc on a
effectivement un transfert d'une partie
de la population qui n'arrivent pas à
trouver de places d'hébergement dans
l'est notamment paris petite couronne
plus que grande couronne entre nous
c'est actuellement le niveau 2 du plan
hivernal qui est en place c'est ce que
je mentionnais tout à l'heure la réalité
derrière c'est à dire comment ça se
traduit justement ce niveau 2 ya trois
niveaux sur le plan puis il ya le niveau
de déclenchement 0 qui est celui de du
1er novembre au 31 mars donc habituel
ensuite le 1 et le 2 en fonction des
températures et le 3 qui n'a jamais été
déclenché dans le département et qui
pour les températures inférieures à
moins 18 degrés donc là aujourd'hui on
est dans le niveau 2 je crois que nous
sommes le seul département mais on l'a
fait pour justement ouvrir des places
supplémentaires 46 pour accentuer les
maraudes pour également permettre
l'ouverture des abris deux jours en
continu notamment le week-end donc
c'était un dispositif qui nous a permis
de faire face aux intempéries à la neige
et au froid des derniers jours et qu'on
maintient jusqu'à vendredi juste un
dernier mot puisque vous êtes donc la
directrice adjointe et de la cohésion
sociale dans le département jean marc
ayrault le premier ministre qui a
dévoilé le plan anti pauvreté c'était
hier un plan estimé à 2,5 milliards
d'euros annuels à partir de 2017 ils
figurent une hausse du rsa un
investissement dans l'hébergement et
l'accès au logement à davantage de
places en crèche également pour les plus
démunis une aide aux familles en
situation de pauvreté avec une hausse de
l'allocation de soutien familial un
complément familial également votre avis
vos remarques sur ces différentes
mesures qui seront développés dans les
prochains jours prochaines semaines donc
nous nous sommes déjà en train de
travailler sur une partie de ces mesures
li est bien évidemment logement élèves à
l'hébergement tout ce qui me concerne
concrètement ça va se décliner en
certain nombre de places à créer en
fonction des besoins recensés dans le
département ça va se concrétise
également par un projet de territoriale
de sortie d'hiver pour éviter de
remettre les personnes accueillies à
l'hôtel ou en structure à la rue à la
fin de l'hiver et ce plan est
particulièrement
axé donc sur la pauvreté et touche
plusieurs ministères ce qui permettra
une interministérielle it et des
décisions qui vont être mises en place
et pas seulement un ministère qui
travaille seul là on va travailler avec
la santé on va travailler avec l'emploi
donc sur tous les axes qui permettent la
prise en charge des personnes en
difficulté dans le même temps juste pour
revenir sur l'actualité du jour en la
cour des comptes qui a annoncé que des
mesures importantes à prendre pour
réduire les déficits se serait de
réduire les allocations chômage ça ne
vous inquiète pas si vous vous dites
peut-être que la précarité pourrait
augmenter et encore plus de difficulté
derrière oui beaucoup de nos publics ne
sont malheureusement pas de toute façon
au chômage ils perçoivent le rsa et
toutes les allocations de transfert mais
je sais qu effectivement ça peut
alourdir la problématique de la pauvreté
c'était une ruine des recommandations de
la cour des comptes on verra comment
bien évidemment réagi gouvernement à
cette demande merci en tout cas yolande
blonde est revenue sur ce plateau pour
nous parler de l'hébergement d'urgence
et du 115 en priorité hébergement dur
suffisant en tout cas vous nous l'avez
dit si on contacte le 115 une personne
sans domicile fixe doit pouvoir trouver
pour la soirée un logement merci à vous
n'oubliez pas ce numéro le 115 la vague
de froid également fait l'objet de
toutes les attentions de la part de
hertz filiale d'edf basée à montigny le
bretonneux à saint quentin en yvelines
elle doit prévenir les pics de
consommation pour éviter des coupures
les explications de valérie auribeau et
d'élodie moines
neige et températures en baisse ont
paralysé les routes ce week end mais pas
le réseau de transport d'électricité en
relation permanente avec météo france
les exploitants du réseau a juste de
façon continue le besoins en
consommation ici dans les locaux du rte
à montigny le bretonneux les équipes
restent sereines nous avons également
actuellement une situation favorable
avec un réseau qui est globalement très
disponible donc une situation qui nous
permet d'affronter une vague de froid
avec un bon espoir et puis grandes
chances que ça se passe bien le réseau
achemine l'énergie depuis les centrales
jusqu'au point de consommation à savoir
les foyers les bâtiments publics et les
entreprises
actuellement la consommation
d'électricité ici en rouge reste en deçà
des prévisions en bleu on a connu des
niveaux de consommation beaucoup plus
élevé l'hiver dernier au mois de février
où la vague de froid était plus
rigoureuse puisqu'on était 10 degrés
sous les températures normales
saisonnières on actuellement à peu près
5 degrés sous les températures normales
saisonnières donc les froids qu'on subit
actuellement sont moins virulents
23 1300 mégawatts consommés l'an dernier
au plus fort de la vague de froid à
l'heure actuelle la consommation n'a pas
encore atteint les 23 1000 mégawatts de
plus la neige sur les toits isole les
maisons et n'entraîne pas de pic de
chauffage mais le manque de luminosité
due à une forte couverture nuageuse
encouragea plus d'éclairage
la situation reste donc stable pour
autant les équipes du rte présente 24
heures sur 24 pour gérer 20% de la
demande électrique française entre l'île
de france et toute la normandie
demeurent vigilants météo france annonce
une chute des températures jusqu'à -4
degrés pour cette fin de semaine
mais là encore
situation semble déjà maîtrisé les
entreprises étant à l'arrêt les samedis
et dimanches le réseau a alors davantage
de marge de manoeuvre pour chauffer les
foyers